so
we're going to continue
with our discussion of
clinical personality theories today
moving away
from the
psychoanalytic or deaf psychoanalytic
theorists or the depth psychologists
we're going to start to talk about the
phenomenologists and the existentialists
and so i need to lay down a little bit
of
background first
and i think
we'll start with a
discussion of phenomenology and
existentialism
now for the phenomenologists this is a
tricky concept to grasp
i think i'll actually start by telling
you that something
something that carl jung wrote about
in the last book he published which was
called mysterium conjunctions which
means
mysterious conjunction
um he sort of
believed
posited that there was some extensions
of moral development past
the higher levels
of moral development that piaget
identified
um and there were three of them
and he said they could be symbolized
by
masculine feminine conjunctions or that
they were in the literature that he had
researched which was mostly alchemical
literature
from the
late middle ages
he said that
one of the goals of
moral development or of psychotherapy
was to produce a union between the
emotions and the motivations and
rationality
and you can see that that's actually
been a theme
for all of the theorists that we've
talked about so far i mean partly what
psychotherapy or personality development
seems to be about is the continual
integration of the personality so that
the person's the psyche isn't at odds
with itself and it can move forward with
a minimum of
conflict that's something related to the
piagetian idea of an equilibrated state
so if you're in an equilibrated state
you don't have the sense that there are
parts of you warring against other parts
because you've been able to weave
everything together
into a coherent identity that covers the
past and the present and the future
so the first stage in young's vision of
what constituted higher development was
the union of the
of rationality with emotion and
motivation and
he saw that that was symbolized in the
literature that he had reviewed by
masculine spirit feminine emotions and
and motivation bang together in one
thing
so that then would be the united
mind and spirit in a sense
and then the next stage
which was symbolized again by the
masculine feminine symbolism it was the
union united
mind spirit with the body and so what
that would mean is that once you got
your act together
so to speak
you would implement it in your behavior
so that there was no
contradictions between who you were
in terms of how you thought and how you
felt
and what you wanted and what you were
actually doing
and modern philosophers have
described what they call a performative
contradiction
which they've
formally described as a another type of
of lie essentially another type of
deceit which is that you say one thing
and do another and it and it's
interesting because it's not
it's not a logical
it's not a form of logical deceit in a
sense because
your conceptualizations are abstract and
your behavior is concrete
but there can still be a contradiction
between the two especially when you
start to understand that most of
what your psyche is representing our
schema for action rather than for
representation so
the point is is that
once
your emotions and your motivations are
working alongside your
rational mind really that your rational
mind is properly nested within them
because that's that's a much more
accurate way of looking at it then the
next thing you should do is act
consistently in accordance with who you
are
so that's stage two both of those stages
are pretty easy to understand
but the third stage is actually a
phenomenological stage you have to think
phenomenologically to understand it
so here's
here's one way of thinking about it so
imagine that
you go home and let's say you've set up
a room
and uh
in that room
it's not a very nice room you know maybe
you've got some posters on the wall and
they're sort of hanging a little
cockeyed and
you know there's
dust bunnies are mating underneath the
bed then
um
you have piles of paperwork that you
haven't done and you know homework and
you know maybe there's the odd crust of
bread or so forth lying about and
when you walk in there
it's you in the room that's one way of
thinking about it
but another way of thinking about it is
that
when you walk in there you are the room
just like you're the room when you're
here
because the room makes up
a part of what you're experiencing
and the phenomenologist would say in a
sense that
the best way to conceptualize
the self in its totality
is
what you experience like everything that
you experience is you
and so what that would mean is that
there's no difference between
putting the posters up on you your wall
properly and
cleaning underneath the bed and maybe
making it and finishing your homework
and putting the room in order so that
you feel
confident and calm there and maybe so
that you even enjoy being there or maybe
even so that it's beautiful there
there's no difference between that and
fixing up your own personality
so then you could say here's another way
of looking at it
and i i do
this i believe that this is a very
profound way of looking at things so
then imagine that you could extend that
it's kind of easy to understand when you
think about it as your own room because
you're in there quite a lot and so maybe
let's say you're in your room 10 of the
day so we could say that the experiences
that characterize your room
are 10 percent of you at least for the
time being and that you can have a low
quality experience and there are high
quality experience in there
um
then let's say that you start
generalizing that to the whole house
you know so then you can start thinking
well
are there problematic places in the
house are there problematic
relationships among the people in the
house
and those problematic relationships are
also you
and
you can tell when there's a problem
because you encounter
undesired negative emotion
in
relationship to some relationship or
in some physical locale within the house
and maybe you could fix that you know a
little incremental bit by incremental
depth you could work on that you could
note that that
negative emotion that you don't want to
have a rise
signifies something it signifies
that that situation in some sense is
non-optimal
and then you could work on strategies to
optimize that
and
you don't do that till you stop making
the presupposition
that there's you and then there's the
house
it's like well the distinction between
you and where you are is a very unclear
distinction so then let's say you're
walking down the street or you're going
into a store
and
maybe your matters aren't as good as
they could be because you know to be
really socially sophisticated is a real
art you can learn it can take you
decades to learn how to do that properly
and people who are really really
socially skilled have a much
much higher quality existence because no
matter where they go
they immediately establish a
relationship with the people that
they're talking to
and then
it's not an impersonal and and dead or
aggravating interaction so you know
maybe they walk into a store and the
first thing they do if someone comes up
and helps them is they look at the
person and you know ask them how they're
doing and you know how their day has
been and they make a little relationship
and you know the person is kind of happy
about that because it sort of pops them
out of their persona role
and then
they can have a little discussion about
what they're doing in the store and what
they want and then all of a sudden it's
a high quality experience and that
person everywhere they go if they're
skilled like that so they're awake and
they're attentive and they're listening
everywhere they go they can have a high
quality interaction
you know and people who learn how to do
that learn to do it partly by noticing
when they're
in an interaction with someone or
somewhere
that if it isn't going
in an optimal manner or if it's
producing
undesired negative emotion then there's
something wrong with the way that
they're being in that situation and they
pay attention to that and see if they
can figure out how to modify it a lot of
it is attention and listening which is
there are key components to say to roger
in psychotherapy is attend attention and
listening
so
you might say well so so
you can go into your room and you can
identify little problems that are in
your room that you could fix
that maybe you would fix and so then you
could start fixing them and that
improves the quality of that particular
environment and then you can start to
generalize beyond you know the locales
that are more specifically
under your control because if if you're
walking down bloor for example and you
go into a store and you talk to a clerk
well the probability is pretty high that
the clerk is at least reasonably
functional so you should be able to get
beyond their
barriers in a sense and have a genuine
interaction with them without too much
difficulty but then maybe you're
wandering down blue and you run across
someone who's schizophrenic and maybe
alcoholic at the same time and well
that's
a part of your experience that might
supersede your ability to transform
right the phenomenologists
and people like rogers aren't
making the claim that you should be able
to solve every problem that you come
across or even that you should try
because there'll be things that you
experience that are so complex and
problematic that you might make them
worse if you fiddle around with them you
know what
you've got to be very careful not to
extend yourself dramatically beyond your
skill level
but you can certainly start in isolated
locales and if you stop
presuming a priori that there's some
radical distinction between you
and the environment that you happen to
be in because it's all your experience
if you stop making that
subject object distinction which is one
of the things that phenomenologists
really objected to because they
concentrated on being as such which was
sort of lived experience as the ground
of reality rather than the objective
world as the ground of reality
if you
if you if you
allow yourself to step outside that
dichotomy
and you start to understand that
wherever you go including the places
that you're in a lot
that there's no distinction between
fixing up those
places when you notice that there's
something wrong with them and you could
fix them up and and fixing yourself up
it's it opens up a whole new avenue to
getting your life together because you
know people always think they have to
work on themselves
it's like it's not this is one of the
things that the psychoanalysts i think
didn't get quite right although jung
touched on it in his later words
there's not
all of you isn't inside your head and
for the psychoanalysts a lot of what the
work that you were doing on yourself was
on your own on the relationship say
between your conscious and your
unconscious mind but tremendous amount
of that was sort of inside your skull so
to speak
but
the phenomenologists the
phenomenological approach enables you to
start
reconceptualizing
the psyche
if as something that extends beyond you
and always will and so that you can work
on its reconstruction
at any level of analysis where
your own nervous system is signaling to
you that there's a problem
and the way it does that is well it's a
variety of ways
but
two of the most reliable ways are
negative emotion
there's a new paper for example that
shows that conscientiousness is quite
tightly associated with proneness to
guilt
so that's the negative emotion that
seems to go with conscientiousness but
so guilt and anxiety and shame and those
sorts of emotions which are unpleasant
also simultaneously signal the presence
of a problem and so you and and and what
resentment that's another good one so
you can instead of having those emotions
as enemies you say well i just want that
to go away you can think okay
there's
my
my being my embodied being is signaling
to me that something is non-optimal here
and then and then it's not an enemy it's
it's because it's it's something that's
trying to improve say the quality of
your present experience and your future
experience and if you don't push that
aside or pretend it's not happening or
assume instantaneously that it's the
fault of the environment or the person
that you're talking to
then that can be incredibly instructive
negative emotion is incredibly
instructive but you have to adjust your
attitude so that you understand that
it's signaling to you the presence of
corrective information if you could just
figure out what that information is and
that can come from anyone a person or a
place or a thing or or
or yourself or
you don't need to make the distinctions
you know and so if you're having an
argument with your partner it's not
going very well
i mean it there's a tremendous
tendency among people to try to
win the argument with their partner
but you can't win an argument with your
partner
because then you win and they lose and
then you have a loser on your hands
and and if you do that 100 times maybe
you're better at arguing
than they are for example or you know or
maybe they think more in an intuitive
way so they can't
dance on their feet quite as fast as you
or maybe the situation is reversed if
you win the bloody argument 100 times
you're not a winner
you're just someone who's beat up your
partner 100 times what you want to find
out is what the hell is it that they're
talking about
and sometimes that takes a tremendous
amount of patience and they should be
doing the same thing to you because very
frequently the things that people are
arguing about
are only the tiny
it's like the snow on the surface of of
a glacier
the real argument is deep deep deep
underneath and unless you listen
intently and for a long period of time
you'll never figure out what it is
you're arguing about and then if you win
the person won't be able to talk about
it and that problem will be there for
the rest of your relationship and maybe
for the rest of your life like unless
you solve the problem it's not going to
go away
now
i'm going to start talking about rogers
specifically by
by going over some of the things that he
had to say about
listening because i think i've learned
more about listening from rogers than
from any other
personality theorist or or
psychotherapist that i've encountered
now
we could go back to the fundamentals of
psychotherapy
i mean
really what you're doing in
psychotherapy is trying to help the
person become a better person
and that's not exactly a scientific
formulation better person you know and
it's a tricky thing to get at because
people can be better persons in lots of
different ways
merely the fact that your people vary in
their temperaments indicate that you
know your way of being a better person
in your way of being a better person
wouldn't necessarily be the same way
you know because you
it's like maybe someone's great on the
violin another person is great on the
piano
the great is the same but but the
instrument is different and i think and
that's a good way of looking at it and
so partly what you do
in psychotherapy and i think you do this
in any genuine relationship is
not only is the dialogue about how to
become a better person the continuing
dialogue is also always about just
exactly what constitutes a better person
so you're talking about the goal and the
process at the same time and what you're
doing is working it out
so the the people go into the
conversation with the specific
orientation and the orientation is
generally with client and therapist is
the client comes with it with a problem
their life isn't acceptable in its
current form
and they come with one more thing which
is the desire to make it better and and
something that you should all know
because this will stop you from tangling
yourself up in your life to a tremendous
degree you cannot help someone
who hasn't decided that they want things
to be better unless they make the
decision that they want to make things
better forget it you're wasting your
time and all it will do is hurt you and
i should also tell you that that was one
of roger's necessary preconditions for
psychotherapy another one was honesty
and communication but the person who was
coming in
for the therapeutic process had to be
there voluntarily
and it's a weird thing and i don't know
how to account for it but
i don't think that you can talk someone
who doesn't want to
have things be better into wanting that
they have to come to that decision on
their own
so they come in with having made that so
it's for example it's very very
difficult maybe it's impossible to do
psychotherapy with someone who's been
remanded by the court you know because
they're there involuntarily and they'll
just put up a wall you know not always
but a lot of the time they'll just put
up a wall and just wait it out you know
you're not going to get in there
with a screwdriver and pry off that
shell
so the person has to step forward in a
sense and say well you know there's
something not right about the way things
are going for me and it could be better
and i
and someone else might be able to help
me figure that out
so and that's a really good attitude to
have by the way when you're listening to
someone because
disagree with them or not or agree with
them or not
there's always the possibility that they
will tell you something you don't know
and like lots of times when people are
talking what they're trying to do is to
impose their viewpoint on another person
you hear conversations like this all the
time they're arguments really and
they're often ideological arguments it's
like
you're right and i'm wrong or sorry
that never happens
i'm right and you're wrong and i'm just
going to hack at you until you shut up
or you agree
really you'll never agree because you
just don't get someone to agree that way
it's it's not possible but you might be
able to
cow them into silence or anger
but that's a dominance hierarchy thing
that's not a real conversation it's just
all you're doing is establishing that
you're you know a lobster with bigger
claws than than the person that you're
trying to
pick at
a therapeutic conversation which is a
genuine conversation is one in which
both the people in the conversation are
oriented towards
a higher state of being while they're
conversing and you can tell when you're
in a conversation like that because it's
very very engaging
in fact if the conversation isn't
engaging
then that's a sign that you're not
having a conversation and that's really
useful thing to know too because here's
another thing i could tell you that if
you take to heart will save you an awful
lot of grief and misery
if you're talking to someone
and they're not listening
shut up
just stop it's like you could tell if
they're not listening and if they're not
listening quit saying words you'll just
feel like a fool anyways because you're
it's like you're throwing ping pong
balls against a brick wall you know
you're not getting anywhere
if they're not listening that's a sign
that the
situation isn't set up
to allow you to progress on the path
that you're
choosing and so then you have to stop
and you think okay what what's going on
here why is the person not listening you
know am i being too forceful am i do
they not understand what i'm saying is
it too much about me
do they want to talk
what's going on maybe they don't want to
be here there's all sorts of
possibilities but that's when you have
to wake up past what it is that you're
trying to impose on the situation and
explore and see what's there and that's
way more interesting than trying to
impose your viewpoint another thing is
that
if you're talking to someone you know i
like to talk to people whose political
beliefs are very different from mine
because i can't really understand
how someone's political beliefs can be
really different than mine you know
because i've got kind of a coherent
representation of my beliefs
but it's very interesting to talk to
people who radically differ because
they'll tell you things that you haven't
considered that doesn't mean you have to
agree with them but it's it's much more
informative to walk away from a
conversation having learned something
that you didn't know
than it is having won the stupid
argument which you can't win anyways
and that's especially the case when
you're dealing with people who are close
to you
that you have that you will have around
for the rest of your life you cannot win
an argument with them
because all that will happen is if you
win they'll get you back
sooner or later
they won't listen to you the next time
you have something to talk about or or
they'll get resentful and then they
won't be helpful or
you just can't win
an argument with someone that you will
have repeated contact with
what you can do however is you can have
a conversation
that's a real conversation and maybe you
can come to terms about the thing that
you're
discussing and that's negotiation you
know it's like
well what do you want but you have to
really want to know it's like you're
we're having an argument okay what is it
that i would have to do
because we're having this argument what
would i have to do in order to satisfy
you
you know and then another person will
think well there's nothing you can do to
satisfy me because you know i'm so mad
at you it's like that's not helpful the
other person has to think okay
what are the conditions for my
satisfaction you know so maybe you know
your partner says you're not paying
enough attention to me it's like all
right what do you want
exactly
you know you want to talk for 15 minutes
at breakfast or do you want to talk for
20 minutes at lunch or do you want to
spend an hour at night watching tv or or
like do you want me to act differently
when i come home and i'm at the door
it's like you're feeling
unattended to
what do you want well then they'll say
well if you love me you should be able
to figure that out
yeah that's wrong because you're stupid
you won't be able to figure that out
because you know what the hell do you
know
so the other person unless they want to
corner you into just being the kind of
loser who can't figure things out which
is why are they with you then you know
they need to think about that it's like
oh hmm what is it that i want from this
person what would constitute more
attention right and that's making that
argument much more high resolution
and then it gives the other person a
chance to actually respond and then you
have to allow your partner to be a
because of course they are so once you
tell them
what you want you have to let them do it
badly like 10 times because they're
never going to do it right the first
time
so sometimes when i'm
i've seen
i've helped people sometimes with
marital problems and one of the things i
often recommend is that they
they go on a date you know they take
each other away from their home where
the kids are usually or maybe not maybe
they don't have kids it doesn't matter
and they do something that's just
focused on each other
you know and of course first of all they
tell me they don't want to do that
it's stupid it's like it isn't by the
way
it's not stupid it's like oh you don't
want to go out and have an enjoyable
time with your partner you think your
relationship's gonna survive when all
you do is snipe at each other and do
horrible things together it's like well
no that's not going to work so then
they'll finally say okay we'll go on a
date they'll both look disgusted by the
whole idea
and then they go and it's like
it's just miserable right
like one person says something to the
other that immediately sets them off
when they're out on the date because
they're kind of mad about going anyways
and then they come back and go well that
just didn't work and we're never going
to do it again
it's like
no
so you're telling me you're never going
to go out and do something enjoyable
with your partner
again
because it didn't work very well it's
like
people don't think about it you know
it's like so maybe when you take your
partner out and you haven't been getting
along it takes you like 10 times before
you have a
relatively okay time
but 10 times if you're going to go out
with them let's say
i don't know let's say you go out with
them every two weeks
25 times and let's say you're going to
be with them for 30 years
if you manage to you know get your act
together so that's 30 times 25 so that's
750 times so
if you practice 10 times then you might
be able to have 740 good
times out together you know that's an
underestimate so 10 times of practicing
is hardly a problem for
for that kind of return
so
this is all part of this rogeria like
following this path is all part of this
rogerian process of listening and
listening is
trying to figure out what the hell the
other person is telling you and
understanding at the same time that they
don't know
like especially if they're upset they're
not even sure what they're upset about
and they don't know what they want you
know because you can you can corner them
by saying well you want to be
attended two more what do you want and
they'll try some weird defense like like
i told you already like if you loved me
you'd already know
which is a cliche
and it's a foolish cliche so you can't
let that stop you
i should i should also tell you the
sorts of barriers that people will put
up if you listen to them too
so
so for example let me let me see if i
can
think about it for a bit
yeah well usually what happens is if
you're if you're pushing someone say but
this is in a listening sort of way it's
like what do you want
why do you want them
what would be the conditions of your
satisfaction you're pushing them fairly
hard to clearly articulate their
concerns and sometimes they're afraid to
do that and if you're trying to hash out
an issue people usually have like five
routines they can go through one is they
block you with some you know cliche or
they say something annoying
and then maybe they've got one other
verbal trick after that and then once
you push through that then they cry or
they get angry and if if you still don't
stop then they stomp off
and so
if you're going to have a successful
conversation about something difficult
you need a routine for each of those
it's like
just because the person's angry doesn't
mean the conversation is over
and just because the person prize
doesn't necessarily mean that you're a
sadist
it's often a often tears are a trip they
mask anger
so and what the person is doing in part
is they're using their emotions as an
exploratory technique to find out
how important is this what what happens
if i just break down will the person
shut up and if the person shuts up they
think oh it's not that important
right because they've been able to use a
technique i'm not saying this is
conscious it's it's it's deeper than
conscious it's just how people rub up
against each other when they're trying
to figure out
how things are structured
and so if you quit when they get upset
then they think oh well
this thing isn't so important that's
worth this much upset
but if you continue well then they'll
run away well one of the things you have
to do if you're in any kind of
relationship is you got to make a rule
which is
you can leave but you got to come back
like we're not done with this you can't
run off
because it's not it's it's it's it's
breaking the the contract of the
conversation
you've got to stay and hash it out
so
okay now i'm going to read you some of
the things that
rogers
talked about
all right so one of the things he talked
about is this
idea called
unconditional positive regard
now
i don't think that's a very good phrase
because unconditional positive regard is
one of those things that can be turned
into a new age cliche
in two seconds it's like well no matter
what you do i'll love you it's like no
there are lots of things you can do that
that that is just that's just not gonna
garner a lot of love
so unconditional positive regard like
it's not like there's not an idea behind
that because there really is an idea
behind that
but it like like i said it got all new
agey after roger's formulated it and it
sounds like well all you have to do is
be consistently positive towards the
person and you know they'll flourish
it's like
first of all
you're going to have unconditional
positive regard for hitler it's like no
and not only that you have a
responsibility not to have unconditional
positive regard for yourself or for
other people because
what you're trying to do is to make
things better and so that means that the
things that make things worse are bad
right if there's better there's got to
be worse
and if you're in favor of better then
you have to be not in favor of worse
so i'm going to untangle unconditional
positive regard a bit and like i said i
think rogers used
his word choice wasn't very good here's
here's a different way of thinking about
it so
if you're in a relationship with someone
and this can even be a very short
relationship it could be the sort of
relationship you have when you go to
talk to someone in the store like i said
if you get sophisticated about it but
let's assume it's a longer term
relationship
you have to decide
what if if you're going to have that
person's best interest in mind when you
have the conversation you've got to have
that as sort of
the top value in your value heartbeat
the reason we're talking
is because i want things to be better
not better for me
you know maybe better for me too but
but the better for me is a subordinate
part of the better the reason we're
communicating is because we both want
things to be better
and then we both
aren't absolutely sure
what it would mean for things to be
better we've got to exchange information
until we figure that out and neither of
us are sure about how we're going to get
there and so we have to exchange
information until we figure out how to
get there and that's that's the initial
axiomatic precondition for a true
conversation and that's unconditional
positive regards like i i
regard the person i'm talking with as
someone
who could
transform in a positive direction
and who's willing to attempt that and
who will communicate to that end even
though they might screw up and you know
there's going to be things in the way
and the sorts of things that the
psychoanalysts talked about as
resistance and then they're going to
regard me the same way and you know i'm
also going to make mistakes along the
way
so
now rogers pointed out that in order to
to communicate with someone in that
manner you had to be willing to put
yourself in their shoes essentially and
he said
you had to comprehend
the alternative phenomenal field so
which is okay well i'm i'm here this is
my viewpoint coming out from this place
and now you have a viewpoint and
they're similar enough so that we can
communicate about them but they're
different enough so that
they're not equivalent and the
differences are actually meaningful
so now i got to sort of pop myself out
of my framework put myself in yours and
figure out where you're coming from
and that's the goal of the conversation
so sometimes that can even help you
figure out where you're coming from you
know because you can say well it sounds
looks to me like you're really angry
and the person will say well no i'm just
i'm just uh i'm sad it's like when
they're all ready they look like they're
gonna bite you and say no no it really
looks like i think you might be
also a little bit angry
and they'll be angry about you saying
that of course but
it may also be that their emotions are
so jumbled together in this sort of
chaotic jumble that they don't actually
know
what it is that they're experiencing
because it's this terrible
unarticulated
chaotic bodily state that is signaling
something but that hasn't been
articulated and so they're kind of a
mess
and your careful observation as long as
they trust you and they should trust you
if they know that you have
their best interest whatever that is in
mind or at least that you're trying that
then they can trust you and then you can
help them clarify
what it is that they're feeling you know
what's sort of coming up from the body
and
what that's associated with and what
they'd like to do with it
roger says
real communication occurs
and the evaluative tendency avoided
when we listen with understanding
now the evaluative tendency he's
talking about is
well let's simplify this a little bit
let's say i'm radically left-wing and
i'm talking to someone who's radically
right-wing and we start talking about
something like
um
income distribution
and the right-wing person says
well let's say the left-wing person says
well there's all these people at the
bottom and they don't have a lot of
money and a lot of the reason that
they're there is because
you know they they've encountered very
very harsh circumstances or maybe they
have an illness or something like that
and uh
you know there's a real distribution of
intelligence and so lots of times people
are at the bottom because they just
don't have the cognitive resources to
climb and the right winger goes rubbish
rubbish the reason that they're at the
bottom is because you know they don't
work hard enough and they don't take any
care with with their long-term thinking
and so
the left winger says well that's just
prejudice and the right winger says well
you're just a bleeding hard liberal and
poof that's the end of the conversation
and that's the evaluative tendency it's
like you just come away the same as you
were when you entered the conversation
there's been no exchange of information
whatsoever all there's been is a
hardening of prejudice and you can walk
away feeling morally superior because
you know you demonstrated what a scum
rat your opponent is and how morally
upright you are
well
that's the evaluative tendency that's
not a conversation that's going to lead
to progress if anything it's going to
lead to like increased feelings of
prideful arrogance on your part because
you know everything and on their part
too and like increased polarization it's
not a helpful way of communicating
you know and this sort of thing as we'll
see
when we move into the more social and
political consequences of
um
failure to communicate it's like that's
a microcosm of what goes wrong in a
society when it really starts to fall
apart you know when the individuals
within the society who have differing
viewpoints can no longer communicate the
whole society shakes and trembles
and you can think about this from a
democratic perspective too because you
might say what's the purpose of
elections
well
people who are aligned with particular
ideology think well we need to win the
election because our viewpoint is right
but
then you might ask yourself well why are
there these other viewpoints
and why do things go so bad when one
viewpoint dominates so heavily that
everyone who has the other viewpoint you
know gets shot that seems like a bad
thing
so
what exactly is going on in the
democratic state and what's going on is
that
there's all these different viewpoints
and a lot of them are temperamentally
informed so we know for example that
liberals
are higher in openness
and lower in conscientiousness than
conservatives
and so the conservatives are
conscientious
but they're not very creative and open
so they're good at running things
they're really good at running they're
good at being managers and
administrators for example but they're
not very good at being innovative the
liberals are good at being innovative
because they're open but they're not
very conscientious so like
and that they they have to be less
conscientious in some ways if they're
going to be creative because
conscientiousness can constrain
creativity and so
for the society to work properly the
people with the liberal temperament the
conservative temperament have to
interact with each other because the
liberals think up all the new companies
and the conservatives run them
so and then in the political state per
se it's like conscientiousness is a
virtue
although it if it's exaggerated too much
especially the orderly part then it can
become tyranny and openness is a virtue
too but you don't want every bloody
thing changing every second
so there's got to be some
constant
negotiated peace between
order and innovation and the way that
that happens is that the two sides
communicate it isn't that one side wins
or the other side wins it's that the
dialogue stays open so that the
viewpoints can be represented properly
and so that as the environment moves
because sometimes maybe the environment
is such that being conscientious is
going to be better and sometimes it's
going to be the environment has moved so
that openness is going to be better
because the environment moves
the conversation has to track those
movements so the society stays healthy
across time and the same thing applies
in any kind of long-term relationship
it's like you marry someone
now you've got two brains
and they don't work the same it's like
you want to have two brains or do you
want to have one that's the first
question you're going to do a lot better
with two
so and then so how do you optimize the
functioning of the two brains well
obviously they've got to communicate
you know there's got to be freedom of
expression and there has to be listening
so that's the evaluative tendency which
is
you're wrong
before i even know what you're talking
about at least i should know what the
hell you're talking about before i
decide if you're wrong and so back to
the poverty issue it's like well what
predicts poverty
well
the sorts of things that the left-winger
talks about that predicts
poverty so do the sorts of things that
the right-winger talks about so if
you're really unconscientious
and that makes you kind of it makes you
the sort of person that will rely on
others to do the work if you're
unconscious you're much more likely to
be poor
and so that's a real social policy
problem too because you have this
horrible problem where you have to sort
out
what's causing the poverty
you know
and who's taking advantage of the
attempts to alleviate it as well as
figuring out
so so that's more of an individual
temperament problem which is what the
conservatives are concerned about and
then you also have to figure out how to
address it on a social level which of
course the conservatives don't like to
think about
but it's not like either side has
nothing to say there's information in
both those perspectives it's problematic
though because when you put them
together the phenomenon becomes
paradoxical and then it's very difficult
to come up with a solution it challenges
your cognitive resources and what the
conservative and the liberal want to do
is just simplify it down to one
explanation
it's sociological that's the liberal
it's temperamental that's the
conservative and so then they have one
answer to how it can be fixed we should
fix society that's the liberal
those people should just get their act
together that's the conservative it's
like yeah well fair enough except
probably the problem is complicated
enough so there's more than one solution
necessary since it's not even a problem
right
poverty is not our problem
poverty is like 10 000 problems and some
of them aren't even associated with each
other you know like there's the poverty
that's a consequence of alcoholism
that's not the same poverty that's a
consequence of say very low intelligence
and that's a completely different
poverty than the non-conscientious
poverty or the abuse poverty or and
there's no reason to assume whatsoever
that those should be amenable to the
same solutions
real communication occurs and the
evaluative tendency avoided when we
listen with understanding
understanding that's an interesting word
because you might ask yourself well what
do you mean when you understand
and it's got this sort of
physical
aspect to it right that's the stand
and then there's the under part which
sort of implies that
to understand something is to be under
it and standing and so
partly what happens is if
if i can listen to you with
understanding what that means is that i
get a clear enough picture of what you
want so that i could change the way that
i am that i am
maybe the way i look at things that like
the perceptual scheme through which i
view the world but also my actions and
if i can extract that from you then i
understand i would be able to take what
you told me
and change myself if i thought that was
appropriate or maybe it would just
happen automatically because now i have
a deep understanding of you
people are afraid of that right because
let's say you've got yourself all hemmed
in with some ideology and you're feeling
pretty
secure about that and then you listen to
some dimwit who's got completely the
opposite perspective from you and
you listen hard and all of a sudden
you've got cracks in your system
you know and then you have to think oh
maybe things are more complicated than i
thought they were everything isn't all
tied together in this neat little
package and that can be unsettling
it's unsettling in fact if you're
listening to someone and you're really
listening and you're not being unsettled
the probability is pretty high either
that you're not listening or that you're
not talking about anything of real
consequence because if it's important
and you're listening it's gonna
shift you you know so there's this it's
going to set you into that at least a
little bit into that state of chaos
and what you're doing then just so you
know
is that instead of identifying with who
you were which is the person that you
were before the conversation you're
identifying with the person you could be
as you move through the conversation and
that's a way better thing to identify
with you know you can identify with your
beliefs this is a piagetian idea are you
going to identify with your beliefs are
you going to identify with the process
that allows you to generate beliefs
and often those things are in
contradiction
because if you identify with the process
that allows you to change your beliefs
then you're
you're you're assaulting your beliefs
even though you might be correcting them
but it's it's
it's
demanding to do that
because you're reconfiguring your
physiology
and there's an intermediary period of
uncertainty that goes along with that
what if they're right
well then what it's like yeah well then
what
real communication occurs in the
evaluative tendency avoided when we
listen with understanding what does this
mean
it means to see the expressed idea and
attitude from the other person's point
of view to sense how it feels to him to
achieve his frame of reference in regard
to the thing he is talking about so
there's also rogers is very
emphasizes very much the idea of
embodiment
so you can listen to someone
you can listen to their arguments with
your mind
it's a very logical process sort of a
rational and logical process and in some
sense that's what you're taught to do
for example when you debate
and the idea there is that you know the
argument
is is a cognitive phenomena and that the
the logic is structured in a logical way
and that the way that the argument is
settled by is by the exchange of
information and the relative coherence
of the to perspective it's a very
rationalistic perspective
and it's very useful to be able to
debate don't get me wrong and have your
mind organized so that you could put
forward a logical arguments like that's
why you're in university so to learn how
to do that believe it or not
and
but it's not the same sort of thing that
rogers is after because when rogers
talks about the interactions between
people it's embodied so like if i'm
really watching you when i'm talking to
you paying attention to your face you're
going to be
like
expressing emotions with your face
screen because that's what it does right
your face expresses emotion so that
other people can infer what it is that
you're up to even more than you know
because if you knew you could just tell
them you wouldn't even need emotions but
what the hell do you know about what you
want that's why you're having a
conversation with someone to figure it
out so you're watching them like mad and
you're watching their posture and maybe
you're mirroring them and you can do
that consciously to some degree but it's
probably better if you just do it
unconsciously and then when you're
mirroring them with your body then you
can feel what they're feeling and then
you can start to draw inferences about
what it is that they want by noticing
how you're feeling this is often one of
the things that will stop people dead in
the source of a conversation because the
other person will get upset
and then you'll watch that and then
that'll make you feel upset and then you
go oh i can't deal with this anymore
because it's too upsetting it's like
well
hmm maybe the fact that it's upsetting
is actually an indication that you
really should deal with it you know you
can't just run away if it's upsetting
upsetting something's being flipped over
that's why it's upsetting
well you don't want to bail out just
because you're upset it's like you know
clue in
that's not the time to quit you want to
maybe detach a bit from your emotions so
you don't get drowned in them so you can
use them in an informative manner but
you don't want to stop that's you got
things going then
stated so briefly this may sound
absurdly simple well i didn't state it
so briefly but it's not it's an approach
which we have found extremely potent in
the field of psychotherapy
it is the most effective agent we know
for altering the basic personality
structure of an individual and improving
his relationships
and his communications with others
if i can listen to what he can tell me
if i can understand how it seems to him
if i can see its personal meaning for
him
if i can sense the emotional flavor
which it has for him then i will be
releasing potent forces of change in him
well so you can imagine like your brain
is always trying to figure things out
well let's extend that a bit it's not
just your brain it's your
psychophysiology it's your whole body is
trying to figure things out right and
you can't just think about it as a
logical and mental process like your
emotions are there evaluative processes
they're trying to give you information
but they're not very articulate
you know it's like you come home and
you're all angry and you're touchy and
your partner says something that's you
know pretty mundane and you know you
just explode
it's like well they say to you why are
you like that and they say well i hate
it when your boots are in the way of the
door it's like oh that's why you're
having a fit is it because the boots are
well they're always there it's like
you can be sure that there's a big mess
underneath that and
it's going to be hard to approach that
person because angry people are also
kind of
you know they're kind of
well they're irritable for sure but they
also have this kind of shell on them
that is touchy they're touchy so if you
touch them you know they'll get
irritated at you and so
if you mirror that if you're listening
to them and watching them then they can
start to figure out that they're angry
and that maybe they're too more angry
than the situation demands and if you
listen to them be angry for a while
which is very annoying right because
maybe they'll be angry at you then maybe
they'll calm down and they'll start to
differentiate that emotion into
articulated statements it's like well i
had a really terrible day at work
well
what was so terrible about it then
they'll tell you a little story and then
they'll say well that's happening all
the time and then you ask them about
that and then they say well my boss is
unreasonable in his demands and so then
you ask him about that and you and you
find out that the person
either has a tyrant for a boss because
sometimes that happens right a real
bully which when and then the answer to
why they're mad about the shoes is
because they should change jobs
right or maybe you find out that
well they have no idea how to say no to
their boss they just say yes no matter
what he or she says and that means
they're too agreeable and then maybe you
have to figure out how they can learn
how to say no and how they have to sort
of check with their resentment to figure
out when they're being taken advantage
of it's like
it's very very complicated
and it's no wonder people want to avoid
it
but you know that's another sort of
truism if someone's overreacting
well they're not reacting to that thing
they're reacting to that thing plus a
whole bunch of things that are related
to that thing sort of
and they don't know what it is
and so then if you listen to them
and they talk about it
they're actually thinking because what
you might think when you're talking is
that you think and then you say what you
think and so you don't have to talk you
could just think but that isn't right
most people don't really think
like they're not
they don't sit down and meditate and
like think logically through a whole
sequence of problems the thoughts sort
of appear in their heads you know
spontaneously
sort of like a reverie but they're not
really
they're not philosophers
you know they don't have that kind of
command of the language
and so then when they're talking to you
they're actually thinking
they're thinking out loud and for all we
know maybe thinking is more effective
when you say it out loud because
maybe i'm wired up so that my brain
assumes that if i'm willing to tell it
to you to make it public that it's more
true than those things i'd like to keep
to myself
and so one of the things you're doing in
a psychotherapeutic session is you're
just letting the person talk
and you know i have clients they don't
want me to do anything for the hour that
i'm with them except shut up
and listen and maybe now and then i can
just
clarify something i have one client in
particular who's very isolated socially
isolated and and this person has come to
see me for a long time
and they just want
this person comes every two weeks and
what they want to do is talk about the
last two weeks
and they want me listen
and so i have i have to be engaged right
i'm listening
and and that's a communicative process
listening right because your face is
changing and you're nodding and you know
you're reacting so you're in the
communication but this person just wants
to talk
and then they sort themselves out
you know and figure out what it is
they're upset about and then that's good
and they can go off and
operate in the world for two weeks and
that's all just listening well just
listening listening is hard and people
aren't taught how to do it
if i can listen to what he can tell me
if i can understand how it seems to him
if i can sense its personal meaning then
i will be releasing potent forces of
change in him
if i can really understand how he hates
his father
that that could be a conversation that
can go on for months or hates the
university
or hates communists
if i can catch the flavor of his fear of
insanity or his fear of atom bombs or of
russia you can tell that this is a
little old
it will be of the greatest help to him
in altering those very hatreds and fears
and in establishing realistic and
harmonious relationships with the very
people and situations towards which he
has felt hatred and fear
so for example let's say someone comes
into a therapeutic session they say geez
i just i was just having a conversation
with my father i just hate my father
every time i talk to him it just makes
me angry
and like that's a that's a low
resolution representation right it's
like one pixel father equals anger
it's not differentiated
and that's a problem because like their
body is responding as if this person
needs to be taken out like you might
take out a prey object or something like
that or destroy because that's what
anger is like right and you're sort of
like you're an object to be destroyed
and it's
there's truth in that because
it wouldn't be elicited by the father
unless there was some necessity for the
anger but it's so
generalized and global it's not helpful
it's like okay let's talk about your
father well how would you do that well
what did he do recently to upset you and
then you listen and you don't give the
person advice about what they should
have done because what the hell do you
know about what they should have done
you might have to listen for 50 hours
before you could offer a helpful
suggestion even then it probably won't
work so you listen and then they tell
you some stories about this is almost
like the freudian psychoanalytic
approach they tell you some stories
about what their father was like when
they're their childhood and then a bunch
of things that pop up in memory and
you know they start laying out the story
it's like they're laying cards out on a
table and they just lay out all these
cards there's like a thousand cards and
they're all representations of the
father and then they sort of exhaust
themselves they're out of angry stories
about their father and then maybe they
say well you know
there he wasn't all bad then they start
laying out some
things about him that
you know he drank all the time but he
was really he always took care of us and
he wasn't he wasn't an angry drunk
you know and and
he stayed with my mother and you know so
what's happening now is the picture of
the father is getting differentiated
right it's not just one pixel it's
differentiated and then you might say
well
okay here's all these angry things
how many of them are still relevant like
how many of those do you have to deal
with and the person will say think well
these you know
80 of these anger things are dead
they're in the past
and
you know
70 of these good things weren't good
enough to make up for the rest of this
mess but then you get a smaller pile of
specific things and then maybe you can
start figuring out ways that or the
person can start figuring out ways that
those might be addressed moment to
moment in new conversations like it's a
strategic plan what's the situation
what exactly is going on here lay it out
and the emotions are a great guide to
that because the first thing you want to
do is
everything that makes you emotional
those are the things that aren't dealt
with yet they're not fully articulated
you don't have a strategy you don't have
a full developed representational system
that's why it's still emotional
so it's like your your body and your
mind come up with emotional
representations first and only as you
work through them which means to talk
about them essentially strategically
they don't even turn into words until
you do that
and that's where i think freud went
wrong those things aren't repressed
although they can be they're not
repressed they just never made it all
the way up to articulated representation
and lots of things are like that
whenever you're in a bad mood it's like
i'm in a bad mood
what does that mean
well you don't know
why don't you know
are you repressing it no you're just too
stupid to figure it out
and so then you got to talk to someone
you know i'm in a bad mood and you know
well you know how are you feeling
they'll
they'll get all spiteful and tell you
how they're feeling and then you know
they start to differentiate it maybe
they'll remember something that happened
at work then you can kind of map out the
mood and that starts to loosen it
we know from our research that such
empathic understanding understanding
with a person not about him is such an
effective approach that it can bring
about major changes in personality some
of you may be feeling that you listen
well to people and that you have never
seen such results
the chances are very great indeed that
your listening has not been of the type
i have described
fortunately i can suggest a little
laboratory experiment which you can try
to test the quality of your
understanding
okay so this is this is lovely
because
you don't often actually get a technique
from a therapist that actually works you
know
you get sort of vague techniques
like help the person lay the cards out
on the table you know it's it's kind of
at a high level of abstraction
but this exercise you can actually do
and you can do it a lot and if you do it
it will teach you to listen
so
the next time you get into an argument
with your wife or your friends or with a
small group of friends stop the
discussion for a moment and for an
experiment institute this rule well you
also don't have to be that formal about
it you can just do it once you know the
team
each person can speak up for himself
only
after he has first restated the ideas
and feelings of the previous speaker
accurately
and to that speaker's satisfaction
now that's so cool because here's the
typical argument so we're arguing i want
to win and so you tell me a bunch of
things and so then i take those things
and i turn them into the stupidest
possible representation of those things
you know i weaken your argument and make
you look like a fool and then i
destroy it
and that's a strong that's by that
you're making your opponent into a straw
man that's the straw man argument right
you take you take what they're telling
you and you caricature it and that way
you can make them look absurd and make
them be ashamed and then of course you
set up this skinny little opponent that
you can just demolish with one punch
it's really crooked and it shows that
you're a coward because what it means is
you have to have an opponent that's you
know crippled and and thin and starving
and and inarticulate before you could
possibly win
before you could possibly progress it's
a pathetic way of having an argument
what you should do is listen to the
person and help them make their argument
as strong as you possibly can
and then deal with that
because then you're sure that you're
you're taking them seriously
so
and to that speaker satisfaction well
that's so cool so we're we're having an
argument i don't know maybe we have an
argument about who's gonna be
responsible for grocery shopping or for
doing the dishes or for cooking or any
of those domestic things that
continually cause couples to
be at each other's throat it's like so
you'll have some arguments about why you
should do whatever it is that you're
going to do
and in order for the argument to
progress i have to tell you back what
you said
and you have to agree that i put it
properly well that's so annoying like it
just runs so contrary to what you want
to do of course you want to
make the other person sound stupid so
you can beat them this way you can't do
that because you have to listen well
enough so you actually understood what
they said and then you have to formulate
their argument
so that they're willing to agree that
that actually constitutes their argument
well
that's really it's difficult but it's so
useful because first of all it does mean
that you understood them
and second it
immediately indicates to them
that you're not just trying to win
you're trying to listen and then they're
much less likely to get all irritable
and angry at you because at least you're
trying to listen you're not making them
into a fool and you know often when
people are trying to tell you what they
want because they're all afraid of
telling you what they want because you
know maybe they never got what they
wanted in their whole life you know if
they've had a history of bad
relationships and poor parenting and
that sort of thing they're just bloody
terrified to tell you that they might
actually want something and so as soon
as you indicate to them that you
actually heard what they said and you're
willing to take it seriously enough to
formulate it properly well then it's
like one step towards trust i see you
did listen you at least know where i'm
coming from it's like that doesn't mean
you agree you know just because you
understand someone's argument doesn't
mean you have to agree but at least you
know what the argument is
you see what this would mean so one of
the things rogers does continually is
therapy and i do this a lot it's like i
listen to the person and they kind of go
through a narrative that spontaneous
narrative often following a chain of
associations as freud pointed out
they'll tell me a spontaneous narrative
and i'll say okay it sounds to me like
this is what you said and i'll try to
you know lay out the argument and maybe
now and then i'll i'll ask for
clarification if there's a part i didn't
understand or if i see that there's a
part that seems contradictory you know
they said this thing here this thing
there and i'll tell them that you know
it seems to me that you said this here
and this here i'm not sure how to put
those together i don't say well that
makes your argument you know incoherent
i say well
i don't get how to understand that and
they kind of go oh yeah there's because
people will admit to that
if you just point it out flatly no it's
like i'm not involved i'm just listening
it's not my problem it's a problem and
that's another thing that's useful too
the other person
is entitled to their suffering
you don't get to take it away it's their
destiny
so you can listen to their problems
without having to think that you know
you have to take them on as if they're
yours you have to mirror them but it's
their problem it's like they have to
figure it out and they and that's good
you need a problem to figure out it's
not necessarily a terrible thing that
they have a problem
it would simply mean that before
presenting your own point of view
it would be necessary for you to really
achieve the other speaker's frame of
reference
to understand his thoughts and feelings
so well that you could summarize them
for him and that's useful too because
you know the way we remember things is
if you tell me a long story
and i tell it back to you
i do not tell it back to you
what happens is i listen to it
and i try to figure out what the thread
of the argument is
and then when i tell it back to you it's
way shorter
and tighter
and that means in some sense it's
it's got all the essentials but it's got
less of the baggage
right that's what you're kind of doing
when you ask someone to get to the point
so they tell you this long story it's
like this tree that is it's full of dead
branches and it hasn't been pruned and
there it's standing there and you know
maybe the living branches you can hardly
even see but you're concentrating on
them and then when you tell it back to
them you just tell them the part of the
story that's alive and they listen to
that they think oh yes that's what i
meant
and then
that means you've changed the memory
right if they agree you've changed the
memory you've you've divested it of all
the excess baggage just like pruning
and that's what you're doing and so that
that dialogue is it's mental hygiene
and that's what people do you know you
gotta wonder well why do we talk
well it's to exchange information yeah
and there's utility in it you know like
if you know how to do something and i
don't you can tell me
but
that that isn't the sort of thing that
people are doing most of the time most
of the time they're telling their
stories this is what happened to me
right and there and then the other
person will say well this is what
happened to me and there's this mutual
attempt to organize that's how people
are organizing their brains we organize
our brains by talking
and so if you don't have someone to
listen to you
well especially if it's over a few
decades you're going to have a brain
that's like a whole forest of trees that
it needs a forest fire doesn't need just
some you know trimming it's really in
trouble
so you need to have someone to listen to
you and best way to get someone like
that is to find a bunch of people and
listen to them because you know of
course then they'll
that's a friendship that's a real
friendship you know because you're both
trying to move towards a better place
whatever that place is
and it's a great relationship then
sounds simple doesn't it
but if you try it you'll discover it's
one of the most difficult things you've
ever tried to do
however once you've been able to see the
other person's point of view your own
comments will have to be drastically
revised well that's partly because now
their sort of vague complaint is
tightened up to a specific problem well
then you have to reconfigure how you're
responding to address that problem
you also find the emotion going out of
the discussion
the difference is being reduced
and those differences which remain being
of a rational and understandable sort
if you're really willing to understand a
person in this way if you're willing to
enter their private world and see the
life the way their life appears to them
you run the risk of being changed
yourself which is that's a good thing
if you're involved in a real
conversation
the way that you will change will be
beneficial to you but it's but it's it's
a challenging thing because it'll mean
that you can't stick to the little
you know rigid framework that you had
entering into the argument you have to
loosen that up and be willing to open
the door and you know change the walls
of your house
you might see it his way that wouldn't
be good you might find yourself
influenced or in your attitudes or
personality
the risk of being changed is one of the
most frightening prospects most of us
can face
well imagine so you're trying to build
yourself into a
fully fledged you
well here's one way of doing it just
hang around with people like you
who think the same way you do and then
whenever you talk they just reflect back
what you have to say or you can start
putting yourself in situations that
you're uncomfortable with you know
pushing yourself a little bit and you go
out where there are people that aren't
like you
and then you think
well how am i going to get to understand
these people and the first thing you do
is you go to pay attention and you go to
listen and then maybe you'll be able to
interact with them and then hoof that's
another
environment that you've mastered and
then there's more of you because now you
can operate here and here and then maybe
you think well that was kind of fun so
now i'll go here and i'll try this and
you go there and you listen and you pay
attention and all of a sudden bang you
can operate there and if you do that
over like a 15-year period you'll be
someone who can go anywhere
and
not fit in exactly that that's like
you're invisible it's not like you're
fitting in it's like you can operate
there
you can talk and listen you can gather
information you can trade you're useful
there
and then you're not going to run
up against people and you know risk
unnecessary conflict because if you
listen to people
you just cannot believe what people will
tell you if you listen to them it is abs
and you can if you can listen to people
they will tell you profound things so
fast that it just makes your head spin
you know because people are really weird
creatures they're like dostoevsky
characters they're
they're peculiar they think in weird
ways and they have weird experiences and
bizarre dreams and ideas about the
future of political theories they're
just as crazy as you could possibly
imagine and if you listen to them
they'll tell you why they think these
things and it's
it's not boring that's another issue is
if the conversation's boring you are not
listening
because if you're listening the
conversation will change so that it
won't be boring so you can tell if
you're in a conversation that's boring
someone at least is not listening and it
could easily be you
if i enter as fully as i am able into
the private world of the neurotic or
psychotic individual isn't there a risk
that i might become lost in that world
most of us are afraid to take that risk
the great majority of us cannot listen
we found ourselves we find ourselves
compelled to evaluate and the evaluation
is i'm going to keep you away i'm going
to pigeonhole you classify you make the
classification negative describe you as
irrelevant and push you aside because
then i don't have to pay attention to
you i don't have to listen and i can
stay in my
box of certainty my little narrow box of
certainty
the great majority of us cannot listen
we find ourselves compelled to evaluate
because listening is too dangerous the
first requirement is courage and we do
not always have it
okay so chirp
carl rogers
he's a phenomenologist so he thinks
it's your experience that's real
you need to represent that experience
and you need to communicate it to other
people and you have to communicate it
within a frame and the proper frame is
we're trying to make things better here
and you know in order to adopt that
frame that's not just a simple statement
right i mean you can tell yourself that
try to put yourself in that state of
mind but to do that you have to really
think through
your value hierarchy you have to decide
like what are you up to
are you here to make things worse or are
you here to make things better
and you know you might say well clearly
i'm here to make things better it's like
yeah
sure
no
that's hard and people are full of
resentment and
fear and anger and they'd be hurt in all
sorts of ways and they want to take
revenge and like they're just full of
contradictory impulses and so
to weave all those contradictory
impulses together and to overcome all
those hurts and disappointments and and
reasons for revenge and resentment
you've got to do all that before you can
say well i'm you know here to make
things better because if you're still
possessed by those sorts of experiences
and contradictions you're going to be
motivated to make things worse all the
time just out of revenge in spite you
know you've been hurt you're gonna hurt
and so
to adopt the framework that rogers is
talking about is it's it's a difficult
enterprise and partly it'll come about
the more you listen because the more you
listen you have the chance to exchange
information the more you'll deal with
those inner contradictions and that sort
of collection of hurts and and
irritations that are corrupting you and
twisting you in the wrong direction
so the rogerian perspective is extremely
useful i it's very useful the reason i
concentrated on that one quote of his
today is because that's such a useful
thing you can try it right away the next
time you're talking to someone
maybe you have a friend who wants to
talk things over it's like listen to
them and then when there's a pause say
well it sounds to me like this is what
you meant and they'll go
yes that's exactly what i meant maybe if
you were really listening they'll be
real happy about that because they
didn't know what they meant they're just
telling you this story about why they're
annoying
and so then you'll think oh wow i got it
and then they'll be happy and they'll
tell you something else and like they'll
walk away from that conversation much
lighter and you will too even though
it's a weird thing because you might
think well if you listen people are
going to dump a bunch of trouble on you
it's like
well yes
but if you're willing to listen despite
the fact that there might be a bunch of
trouble dumped on you then you've also
told yourself that you're the sort of
person that can tolerate having a bunch
of trouble dumped on yourself and that's
like that's a
that's an extremely
positive attitude to take towards
yourself
you know and you're not just saying it
you're acting it out and so that's a
sign of faith in yourself and you're not
well i said you were stupid like you are
in relationships but you're not totally
stupid you know you'll be able to notice
that
you you you've been willing to expose
yourself to a risk
and when your body and your mind you're
watching that they'll think oh
i'm the sort of thing that can
voluntarily expose itself to a risk
well that's like the secret to making
yourself strong
it's exposure and so you can do that in
every conversation and that toughens you
up as well as informing you it's a very
powerful technique so i would recommend
try it see what happens it's really it's
also fun because
it's like you're following a thread of
the conversation if you're really
listening the conversation will continue
and it continues in a meaningful way
and then you know that you're in the
right place and it's like a challenge to
your capacity to pay attention
and then you get engaged in the
conference all conversations you get
engaged in them and then you're in
engaging conversations all the time
that's a good thing so
okay we'll see you
there's